my personal style in three words is
goofy teacher boy I think my personal
style is dapper it's sexy it's
functional I really want people to to
see that I'm like a creative I'm a
dreamer I'm like a powerful woman you
know someone who is out here and just
killing it I like to combine both
masculine and feminine energies and the
way I dress anyone can buy fashion
anyone can learn fast you down at the
school but style is something that is
eternal that you carry with you
throughout life so I'm all about my
style baby
I've always dressed on the more
masculine side of things it was cargo
shorts in middle school and then again
in college and now thank God the cargo
shorts are gone my clothes make me feel
confident they make me feel like myself
it make me feel joyful actually January
is fluidity as it's been said of many
times over and over again but it's truth
and my gender is fluidity being a bigger
body it's harder to find things I feel
like they have the right fit and like
fit feel like they're like the right
style for me when I was growing up I
wore a lot of dresses and heels and I
look very nice in them but it just
wasn't what I was comfortable in
sometimes I might have something long
and very extremely feminine but
sometimes I'll do a dungaree or jumper
and a baseball cap to the back it really
depends on my mood I want my clothes to
make me feel like the sort of goofy
butchy mask that I am I don't shop at
stores too often it's very difficult to
find anything there for me but I hope
that anyone who looks at me is inspired
to do whatever they want to do to
express themselves and not ask for
anyone's permission I would have to say
Jaden Smith is a fashion icon dresses
and flowery crowns
boys and dresses boys and dresses Hoss
I think non-binary fashion to me is
freedom I would love to walk into a
store and it's not based on you know
men's section women's section but really
about the styles and the fits and the
you know different body types no bounds
no walls there's no rules there's no
limits being an androgynous person like
I don't care if I like it I'm going to
wear it I'm going to match it and style
it so it fits my body and my lifestyle I
think non-binary fashion is just like a
game of figuring out how I feel in a
moment it allows us to dress ourselves
the way we see ourselves within and the
way we feel within you know clothing is
you know based off of societal
constructs and so my expression of that
doesn't have to be what other people
want me to look like masculinity is just
so fragile that you know any kind of
change towards it it's just a oh my god
I think it's really brave for people to
make the choice on a daily or weekly or
monthly basis to dress in a way that
fits their authentic selves
[Music]
we can see clearly here that gender is a
complicated construct